hello and welcome to the lobby
gamespot's weekly hang out every tuesday
at two p.m. pacific right here on
gamespot com I'm your host Daniel Dwyer
hello to you watching us live until
watching us on gamespot com or YouTube
in the future and with a big old review
go up this weekend mr. Peter Brown you
spent most of last week playing at ten
at ten from metal gear solid 5 the
phantom pain you bet super excited about
it I'm very excited about it yeah I
certainly 50 hours playing it last week
and I'm not ready to stop playing it
time soon at your review ends up on
Sunday a great review very spoiler-free
which I think a lot of people appreciate
it I had you in mind thank you yes and
we're gonna keep it the same way here
today so we're got we've got a master
reviewer segment I got a bunch of
questions from people via Twitter in the
gang spot comments and and I'm skirting
away from story stuff and you're like
gonna be the second like protection yeah
so if I ask something that's even
skirting a little bit just you know just
round it off and and keep it nice and
general okay round before i get into the
questions for those who haven't read the
review yet what are your sort of main
takeaways from phantom pain yy-you ten
at a ten what makes it like an
astounding must play game I mean metal
gear solid 5 has a very big legacy
behind it right so it's it's both a
singular game in a game that fits within
the middle of a grand saga that's been
going on for almost 30 years now so the
game is it's on its own apart from the
other games it is a an open-world action
game that is filled with so many
thoughtful touches and you can tell
there's just like incredible amounts of
consideration that when it's absolutely
everything just the simple act of moving
feels great just looking at the world is
rewarding like I mean every single
moment I spent with this game I I found
something that just that get it struck
me with awe like I it's there's just so
much to talk about and then as a part of
the Metal Gear sada it delivers on so
many things that people are hoping for
which is a connection back to the very
first game Metal Gear that came out in
1987 before the solid series began the
MSX games the MSX games yeah and so I'm
a big fan of open world games I've got a
question my myself what's it like
exploring this world it's is it a game
that's very linear that you
going from base to base that you know
where you your to go next or does it
feel like an open world that you're
discovering elements that you might not
have necessarily needed to bump into
there's a lot of emergence stuff like
you're describing you know you sort of
you go about this world and you know you
have a list of missions that you can
choose from that you know new ones open
up but you have multiple to choose from
and you can pick one or the other and
even when you pick one you can fly in by
chopper and you're only certain landing
zones so you have to show up at a
certain point of the map and then travel
to your base and when you're doing that
you encounter wildlife that is
aggressive or maybe you view them as a
resource that you can capture and send
back to mother base that's another
really big important aspect of the game
so there's a lot to do beyond just
here's a mission go for it i mean when
you're in the world there are so many
things to do that it's easy to forget
about what your mission is if you really
take in everything and consider all of
your options is it surprising to you
that it's such a well-crafted open-world
game considering holy konami have ever
done well kojima productions have never
done every single middle your game has
been you know like missions set in very
contained areas with a linear path from
one to the next and it's phenomenal what
they've done I mean you know I think you
can start with a massive map and throw a
character in there and call it open
world and you know that that is the case
here in a way but there are just so many
things piled on top of that that
skeleton of what defines an open-world
game that I was totally blown away I
mean this game has been in production
for five years and you know it shows I
mean there it's there's never a shortage
of things to look at or do and it's it's
incredible I'm gonna get into the user
questions as quickly possible because we
got a bunch of them here first ones in
from final show friend of ours at BC
plasma asks is there a reason to explore
around an open world what kind of
collectibles can you get in Metal Gear
Solid 5 so all of the equipment and
technology that you unlock and develop
in the game happens back at mother base
which is an offshore base where you were
sort of building a private military and
throughout the open world you find
natural resources you find wildlife you
find people of all things and all of
these can be collected and sent back to
your mother base so you're incentivized
to collect those because all of them go
into you know research and development
of new technology which isn't necessary
to to beat the game you can skirt by
with almost a bare min
and throughout the whole thing but you
have to be incredibly good in order to
do so so you're incentivized to collect
things to develop new tech to make your
life easier but it also makes the game
much more varied and interesting because
some of the tools you all knock are so
crazy and they just they may be a sense
of like Wonder and joy you know from
like this little thing you add to your
arm lets you punch the ground that sends
out a sonar wave I mean it's yeah so
there's there's plenty to collect and
there's plenty of reasons yeah collect
that stuff excellent and do you sort of
decide what you're upgrading during that
it's not like if you get like seven if
you Fulton age goats you get like some
sort of special goat armor no so
essentially when you collect enough
resources let's say you chitin of people
right that levels up a certain part of
your base wherever you place them in a
certain field of development hmm when
you hit that level in that field it then
unlocks the ability to to craft a thing
but then to actually craft it you use
the natural resources and the money that
you earn my calculations sweet it's
actually kind of reminds me of XCOM yeah
where you're like putting people in
specific places yeah and then and what
you collect that on the field sure
translate that's pretty cool john class
on twitter asks i played all the Metal
Gear Solid games except for is there any
important information from one that I
should know heading in so I guess the
sort of wider question to that is can
you enjoy this game without having sort
of an encyclopedic knowledge of those
four games or maybe MSX ones and if
there was one or two games that you need
to know more about which ones would they
be one of the great things about this
game and I think what was really smart
of Kojima to do is to create a story
that is interesting enough in its own
right without the connections to games
from the past or games set and you know
in the future in the timeline a large
chunk of the story is dedicated to this
specific thing that anybody can get into
I think the cinematography the voice
acting and the writing are also good and
like yes it's ridiculous like the things
that happen in this game make no
freaking sense but the the the emotions
that are conveyed in the voice acting
and the the trauma that these characters
endure that you watch sort of culminates
a new experience that you can enjoy just
on its own you don't have to really play
the other games do you but if you have
the sort of last section of the game
really does reward all that dedication
yeah for a series that spent like
you know almost three decades long I did
it feel like a like an incredible and
did you want to like immediately grab
somebody else who play the game and like
talk about it oh it's absolutely but I
would say that I think a lot of people
are expecting that this game will sort
of answer very specific questions and
tie things up in a really tidy box but
if it answers a lot of questions but at
the same time I mean do we really want
to know everything about these
characters I mean so much fun about the
seedings is speculating speculating
about their origins their motivations
their relationships kojima must know
that because the ending to this game
opens as many new questions as it
answers Wow so I yeah yeah that's let's
stop it there and I guess then for for
people who don't maybe you said that
like obviously the game is enjoyable in
its own right does the does the game go
to any lengths to try and like fill in
information like give you a little bit
of catch-up svea codex or via like story
aside yeah remind you what was going on
yeah you collect cassettes in the wild
cassette tapes and you you earn them as
rewards for certain mission and those
contain tidbits of the past the game
also gives you a bit of a preamble to
let you know what happened like leading
up to ground zeroes and in ground zeroes
which was the prologue to this game so
it does inform you a little bit about
the story leading up to it the stuff
that comes afterwards that is not
spelled out so much there is some of
that towards the end of the game where
they reveal like sort of the result of
the outcome in this but yeah you know it
doesn't it's not like you have a huge
compendium of information to like sort
through which I guess you also never
really had in the old games either you
there was an element of like going
online and trying to figure bits and
bobs and then yes metal gear solid 4 had
this like incredibly large optional
database of information to install that
is an encyclopedia for the series more
or less so yeah I mean no game of the
series has really gone to the lengths to
tell the entire saga but I think this is
a good job for people who are curious
there is stuff to dig your teeth into
cool and next one up daniel NOS de NOS
at sky war on twitter asks have you
tried the pc version any chance of
another Arkham Knight type scandal and
what version did you play how long do
you
play en played the pc version no so who
knows no I played the playstation 4
version for just about 50 hours and you
know the the game holds up incredibly
well technically one thing I did notice
it has really great draw distances and
you sort of landed a huge environment
and you really do appreciate like wow
like I can see so far into the distance
and things look great while you don't
see pop it in the distance on the ps4
version you do see some in the
foreground but I think the fact that you
have so much to gawk at that's that's
larger and more impressive you know that
sort of distracts you from the little
blade of grass like a foot a foot ahead
of you that maybe didn't pop up yet yeah
and I think it's a good trade-off but
speaking of the pc version if you look
at Ground zeroes that game is phenomenal
on pc it just looks I mean the console
versions look wonderful anyway the pc
version is just amazing and this is done
in the same engine it's for all
intensive purposes the same you know
build of a game you know in a way so i
would expect the pc version to be great
i haven't tried it yet but that's what I
expect cool I will you be trying us next
week when it comes out I don't worry
attacks on when I come when the game
comes out or we're just a document oh
you're not going I'm not going to pack
this is sticking around thing more like
a solid actually yes some [ __ ] slam it
k Donder asks via Twitter how hard was a
mega solid five moderate difficulty too
hard at points was any parts we found it
difficult or there are absolute
difficult points towards the end of the
game especially and this is one of the
issues this probably the only issue I
had with the game is that as you
approach the end of the story normally
you beat a story mission you unlock a
new story mission that natural
progression what happens at the end of
the game is the game forces you to play
older missions at extreme difficulty oh
wow and you have to do that in order to
unlock new ones in my mind that's to
pass the time it does sort of throw off
your sense of progression in a timeline
because you're like I did that you know
20 hours ago it doesn't fit in the story
if I'm trying to do that again is it
more difficult because the point is it's
more difficult no because they it's like
total stealth like the moment the enemy
is alerted you fail the mission you know
or you have no equipment like you
basically go in here it's like arbitrary
sort of yeah
of that some of those you can cheese
like you do gain the ability to to call
in air raids those costs resources and
it lowers your ability to reach a
certain level of rank right um but yeah
if the going gets tough you do have
tools at your disposal be at that or you
know one of the buddies you can take
with you makes life much easier and yeah
so the game is hard but it gives you the
option this to make it easier on
yourself if you simply just want to beat
it and continue cool a couple more
questions here Vova asks does the
open-world nature of the gameplay
translates to or impact the story so i
guess the sort of take from that would
be do these feel like isolated missions
you're kind of walking to and from does
does the choices you make in the open
world bleed into the story at all like
can you do like only this mission and it
changes the stories of one well I think
the open world does for this game which
I don't know if this is answering this
question specifically but it gives you a
lot of time to spend with big boss hmm
and you know as you sort of feel a
connection to the events he's going
through that ends up being a lot of time
with yourself and your own thoughts and
if you consider that he is the main
character and this is a story
surrounding him the fact that you have
the time to reflect on what he's going
through where he is and what he's doing
to me lends itself lends a good
connection between the open world and
the story mission because if this was
just a story and the gameplay was just
there to support it it would be more or
less a movie but this game is unlike
subject you know some people pointed at
mill your solid for and they were like
it was like 20 hours of cutscenes like
this you know the gameplay stuff is on
the secondary here this really is about
being in the world that exists as the
character and so I think that the open
world is actually a great stage for big
boss and that's the story at large yeah
another great aspect of this series of
course is the sort of the cinematic
quality of its presentation and
certainly the cutscenes especially in
well I guess the whole series going
through like Metal Gear Solid one was
known for it for was was pretty
incredible and had his five sack up in
terms of that aspect of it are we
looking at 15 20 minute long cutscenes
that could have been shorter or does it
feel like it's been well directed and
edited there are cutscenes that you may
say or 15 minutes roughly
you know those come at certain beats
when you've been struggling really hard
to accomplish something and get to a
point in the story and those are a
reward in a big way because you are
fighting to understand what is happening
next and considering that the high
quality of the framing composition the
voice acting the lighting I mean even
just down to the the art style like
these cutscenes are great and you know
they're there are a bunch of them but
you spend the majority of your time
playing this game rather than watching
it cool last question I think one or two
more maybe and first one this one's sort
of an amalgamation of a bunch of
questions people have asked Devon hall
ask where do you see the series going
post Kojima if at all where will we go
for akron isms a movie chat does this
feel like does this feel like the last
night of your game from what you played
like regardless of story where it does
or what I mean tipping on the story does
it feel like they're this is wrapped up
and we'll have kijima making different
games from their own uh I do not believe
Kojima will be making another metal gear
game I don't see how that's going to
happen giving the politics at Konami and
given the place in the story and
honestly the scope and scale of this
game it's the amount of work that's gone
into this is is immediately apparent and
it never fails to remind you of the fact
that this is this is his opus this is
like an amazing body of work and it's I
don't think we'll ever see a game like
this from Kojima in the Metal Gear
universe ever again and last question no
spoilers do you feel ashamed of your
words and deeds uh my words indeed
number the Twitter the tweets act kajima
said about Oh wyoss Oh without getting
into us okay there's there's
justification in the story but it wasn't
necessary okay fair enough i'm peter
brant thank you so much going on metal
gear solid 5 the phantom pain review up
on gamespot com right now if you want to
check it out go over there and let us
know what you think in the comments
below but first of all Peter Brown
Peter Brown I want to ask you about a
little bit of sort of miscommunication
that happened last week where konami SPR
decided to take their time clarifying
something so telling me a little bit
about the sort of the element of
microtransactions that exists in the
player versus player aspect of your cell
phone so I'm gonna lay this out by
explaining that there are two
multiplayer modes to the game okay
there's middle gear online that is
coming in october yes that is like two
squads face each other and fight and you
haven't seen haven't played any of the
plate any of that okay the other
multiplayer component that goes live on
launch is called fo b which stands for
forward operating base in the game you
manage a base called mother base Forward
Operating Base is a secondary base that
you use to you know you add more
soldiers to your crew there and they
help you develop stuff you can elect to
go into a PvP mode where other players
can invade your base and you can defend
it against them likewise you can invade
other players bases and there's like a
risk/reward of different resources and
stuff that come with fast food truck so
when I was playing the game I was
playing offline when I got the ability
to build an fo b it said I had to spend
and be coins to purchase the water to
make place for the business then said mb
coins are a paid service so to me that
said okay this mode is locked behind a
micro transaction I reached out to
konami last week days and days ago and
said it looks as though i need to pay
money to access fo b because presumably
the MBS or whatever that currency was
supposed to be something in the game
that you would also earned annoying so
no okay there's so many layers of
confusion okay sorry so email Konami and
said what are the costs associated with
fo b how do I get it like what are all
the steps their response was oh we'll
have more information for you next week
we don't have anything to share right
now they had that opportunity to tell me
hmm I then put up a new story after
playing the game saying well it looks
like that in order to do fo b you have
to buy mb coins which the game calls a
paid service Konami reached out to me
and said hey that's not true we've said
that in the past and I asked them
yesterday morning again well then give
me more information I need to know how i
unlock this without spending money
because I saw that the screenshot as
well from your while you were playing
and it says it like twice yeah this is
you need to buy these and there's no
other option it contradicts what Kaname
had said in the past yeah but the fact
is I had
final retail copy the game and that's
what it was telling me ultimately ended
up talking to someone else who is at the
review event who was a YouTube streamer
and they played a build of the game that
was focused on multiplayer and that was
using an internal server by Konami they
play the mission that unlocks the
ability to open up fo be so I don't
understand how this works but because
they were connected online the game left
them by the initial Forward Operating
Base using in-game currency that they
have been earning the whole time so even
though that that's not a micro
transaction connected to a server they
had to be connected to a server for it
to enable them to do that oh that okay
that is weird is backwards thinking yes
me being offline I never got that option
so I never saw evidence of the fact that
you get a Forward Operating Base for
free this was all clarified last night
the first fo be that you can build you
can build using in-game currency every
other base after that you have to
purchase using MV coins I don't know how
much they cost Konami doesn't know yet
according to them I don't know how many
mb coins you're gonna have to spend they
still don't know that either right you
can also use mb coins to speed up
development of certain things as you get
to higher levels bases like new
platforms take like an hour to generate
or something hmm so as accelerators like
games like whatever you know farmville
or but i have x know your solid five is
exactly like farmed or for public
shelter pray there you have it it's a
stick it on the box and outside of the
the confusion of edge yeah and that's
sort of the still confusion about
exactly what the limits are on this that
can we still haven't kind of clarified
and doesn't kind of suck that this stuff
is in there like a solid five like it
seems almost complete this what this
kind of looks like to me is that like
kajima made this game and then this is
the bit the Konami bunch of and decided
to do this lame Micron's transaction
aspect which seems almost unnecessary
I'm of two minds when it comes to this
issue I mean one I I don't appreciate
microtransactions I mean who loves them
in a full-price game nobody but at the
same time this game specifically like
politics and grand stances aside what
I've played already I am so satisfied
with what I got out of metal gear hmm
the fo b stuff being there and that you
can participate in it for free
sounds good to me I played some of it
granted it was on one of the saves from
Konami which was like a really high
level bill so I wasn't attached to what
I was losing or fighting for it was a
fun mode but it's not the sort of thing
I personally want to sink a lot of time
into and I don't know that a lot of
people who are going to really buy this
game are going to be looking for that
specifically either I don't think it's
great I think you know if it's in there
it shouldn't cost any money I'm not
personally bothered by it because i'm
not going to invest a lot of time in it
i don't think but hey you know if you
want to try it out you can and
unfortunately you don't have to spend
more money if you want to get deeper
into that and I can't apologize for
anybody doing that that that's a shitty
situation to be in and you know I wish
it wasn't the case yeah and hopefully it
won't be that much money but I guess
time will tell cannot be a lot of snow
last question do you believe just in
seeing what they've done with that that
will see some sort of microtransactions
appear in the metal gear online portion
of the game coming later in the year
yeah why not you think what yeah I mean
I don't see why I mean look yeah if
there's evidence to support that they're
gonna do if thing included with the game
at launch you know I'd be amazed if it
wasn't also in Metal Gear Online I mean
surprise surprise me Kaname surprise us
yeah don't surprise us actually cuz all
the times you've been surprising it's
over the past year rose kijima stuff is
maybe a bit too much for our poor little
heart appear brand thank you so much for
coming on yeah I sticker Rams oh we got
a bunch more stuff to talk about today
on the lobby an x-ray career I think I
saw it just wanderin eye means gonna
talk about until dawn in a second Mike
my hardly somewhere nest as well he's
gonna come on and talk about gears of
war but first of all dishonored came out
it's what years this 2012 what years
this what he hears this great yep
a bunch of guy games have come out and
are coming out this week and next week
video games the back bye bye summer and
alexa ray korea's here to tell us all
about until dawn yeah I game I played
I'm preview a while ago and I think I
felt bad for this but I think my biggest
sort of take away from it was wow this
was a lot better than I anticipated I
thought this was going to be a piece of
garbage turns out it's it's okay and you
gave it a eight out of 10 I give it an
eight I too went into until dawn
expecting hot flaming garbage chef and
had way more fun than I anticipated I it
is summer sleeper hit and I'm actually
really good like why maybe I can
understand it but I'm kind of bummed out
that Sony is not throwing the kind of
marketing support behind that they
should that Kim's great yeah I'm a
little bit surprised to I wouldn't have
been before I played it though so maybe
that's telling of why they're doing that
and I've got a bunch of questions from
folks via Twitter yeah but first of all
what are your sort of main takeaways
from on tilt on what makes it fun what
makes it better than just another David
cage pit point kick the bottom when you
slipped up button more polygons more
motions um there are a lot of them of
motions and until done I so I am on like
the telltale games review train like I'm
playing all of their games right now
I've been playing all their games and
they do this thing where they're like
all right your narrative choices affect
the story but with telcel games it's
like okay you're gonna make choices but
you're still gonna arrive at the same
narrative point until dawn still has
those narrative points that you have to
hit and those beats that you have to hit
but in terms of how the story goes you
have complete control over when and how
and who dies like at any time so you can
complete this game having everyone
survive and can also yes quote unquote
complete this game was having everyone
died wait so I've controlling this at
any time well you've been beginning the
game if I way no way let's just get this
over with like so there are throughout
the story like there are different
opportunities for each character to die
there's one segment with one character
where she could die in any number of
I think it's like four ways over like a
20-minute people really dependent if you
miss if you miss like one quick time
event I know it's great Sasori this
place will be okay yeah this isn't a
spoiler cuz this may all gods oh that's
awful uh robot oh oh those two little
intestines yeah we're just clinging on
for dear life because you can compete
the game and having that dude survive if
you want you can make it them all
survive you can make them all die I
won't tell you how that's all you to
find out but I press X today today is X
to calm down dear it's [ __ ] ya know the
deer the deer are a big thing ok big its
a spoiler if I mention it but ya don't
ya okay crap ok here anyway well I would
ask you question right when I was
playing the first I paid me the first
three hours in this preview it felt like
up until then maybe there wasn't that
much in terms of people dying is it
after that stage that all the like
craziness starts to happen so you get
about an hour and a half into the game
and the carnage starts ok but there's
sort of like a the game sort of takes
its time to introduce the characters
tell you what kind of character the
characteristics they have and what their
relationship is like with the other
characters and as you go through the
game in addition to dying you can
improve or destroy their relationship
with other characters they have like an
affinity meter mmm um but the and that
affinity meter actually matters there's
a give one example of how crazy and how
deep this narrative web is but there's
an instance where you can choose to
either have yourself harmed or a another
character of the female persuasion home
to marry me not have a crush on you and
if you choose to harm yourself uh later
in the game she actually the way that
she talks to you is very different
should be like yeah you know thank you
for saving my life thank you for
whatever and there's an instance where
later down the line you're being chased
toward the house by this this My Thing
Thing and she will actually appear and
open the door for you and pull you to
safety okay if you do not choose to save
her she doesn't quite know that you
didn't choose to save her in there in
one instant rice in
she says thank you for saving me thank
you for saving me but if you didn't
choose her the character that you're
playing as will actually be like instead
of being like yeah no man I had to save
you had to save you he'll just be like
yeah yeah because he didn't pick to save
her and she's alive Wow so in the second
instance if you also don't choose to
save her you're in the same instance
running towards the house thing chasing
you she'll stand in front of the door
and just watch you get mutilate oh wow
Jesus it's critten and she'll like the
way she talks to is different the way
she behaves with you is different like
like all of those little choices do
ripple out and they can cost you or the
character of life cool it's very deep I
got a bunch of questions I want to get
into a basil Frank at red tie guy
frankly asks how much replay value is
there would you really want to play it
again once it's been completed I've
replayed it four times are you through
here's yep well I when I played the
little segment that I did I went back
immediately and did it again half out of
like you know oh I should see what this
also looks like but I actually like it
was like 11 at night I wanna [ __ ]
actually want to get into this and I
play it again Peter are you interested
in playing on till Donnellan are you
found of like David cage type games no
I'm not but this game is sort of
intriguing because I do like horror
stuff and everyone is just raving about
this so I'm kind of like okay I guess I
really should play this busy as hell me
i think i'm gonna guess others boy you
could have complete completed ten times
and all the time you play more than that
probably more that my god and next
question comes in from mattis mocha ash
it's my favorite part of show just
saying mantis mocha I'm just saying
people's twitter names ash my tush svk
and does butterfly effect really matter
and do the choices you make are they
important in the future or is it more
like telltale games well you already
answered a question that again read my
review and the antagonist in this game
antagonists what okay what I want to ask
you is okay without getting into like
the spoilery stuff cuz it is it does
feel like there's a lot of [ __ ] going on
and there for a while it felt like cabin
and woodsy where I'm it was almost like
the game is trying to pick which version
of like evil it was trying to get me
well I only played like the first
whatever our two in a felt like that so
in between the levels doozies like
conversations with this with this like I
like I just which were my favorite part
I think of doing because in between them
he's like super breaking the fourth wall
like going up to you and saying like you
enjoying your game and you know which do
you find more you know terrifying any
give you all this collar needles are
spiders out of one sage if you take too
long with it he like like jumps at you
and goes why are you taking so long holy
[ __ ] yeah he gets in your face and it's
that actor guy that everyone knows who
nobody knows yeah i forgot as me but I
know who is how much does that stuff
bleed into the game does it or does it
not like done okay it in a satisfying
way yes sometimes it's little ways like
an antagonist coming after you will
either have like a gas mask or a needle
yeah it's like clown face okay or or the
antagonists oh man or like something
well I'm trying not to spoil it cuz he
talking you have a manager solid and
until dawn today's we haven't anything
to offer can't wait for the metal gear
for the gears of war guide to come on
let's look at nobody gets it Tom's wife
dies but like but like oh oh trying to
give an example us on a spoiler okay so
one of the conversations I think it's I
think it's in chapter 5 so this is not
spoiler for Sony's guidelines so there
is a there's there's an incident where
the psychiatrist is all right let's
figure out how you feel about all the
other characters and you're given a
pictures of each character and you have
to pick the head you're giving pairs I
remember that and by choosing the ones
that you like the most out of each pair
the game determines who your least
favorite character is I bet we pick the
same person who's your favorite [ __ ]
girlfriend Jessica the one I'm sorry no
just wait we release no Emily short hair
the one who wouldn't pick up the bags
why don't I say where was right what a
[ __ ] she's such such a [ __ ] and she
actually I I have played four times and
I tried to do was save them all
playthrough and I just killed her I'm
like no you're so annoying and I can't
deal with you so she's dead that's great
that's how i found the bad as always i
was actually looking forward to a
situation in which i could have her
[ __ ] kitten yeah it's an she can die
at like four different ways right crazy
um but the game determines who your
favorite characters are and it's
seems to me based on what what I have
played that who your least favorite
character is the game keeps him alive
longer because she was really really
really hard to kill like like and then I
tried not picking her and I tried
picking um who was it Jessica yeah it
was really hard to kill her and I think
the game takes note of who your favorite
character is and then just sort of like
gives them more [ __ ] to deal with that's
amazing okay but with four players I've
seen very very like different stuff it's
crazy cool ah thanks very much for on
yeah it looks at last question a lot of
people asking obviously with the
replayability it is good you can play it
again you're still talking about maybe
like 10 hours with two playthroughs does
it feel like a game that's worth sixty
dollars yeah for the amount of content
that's in it you just don't see it the
first time around in addition to the
story the story that you're given
there's all those clues you have to find
I mentioned them in my review but those
sort of shed light on the story and
sometimes not finding a clue means life
or death for certain people or certain
situations so there's a lot to it
there's no way you can see everything
the first time around and I definitely
think it's worth it if you weren't
reviewing it would you like to keep
replaying it though I think I said
that's the question on my mind because I
know people might play through it once
and think yeah I got this out of there
right but I spent 60 bucks for that my
second two places were after my review
my life yeah cool yeah and a satisfying
our satisfying in a different way
problems that's not gonna different week
something I want to see this guy dying
spoiler like I just want like it's fun
it's actually more than fun is it better
than beyond two souls yeah Mary also
agrees there you go yeah oh great thanks
so much for coming on eight out of 10 on
gamespot com that's until dawn and make
sure you check out the review on the
site and let us know what you think
about the game and if you're hyped about
it in the comments below I am breads
coming to ps4 really really that's an
actual I am bread Quinn ps4 did they put
in the voice-over you guys did I wish I
baked a voiceover and I didn't couldn't
afford him why gonna do and for all your
fans of bread and controlling Brad's
here's your's I'm Brad come to
PlayStation 4 bread bread
I was just thinking about this honor
definitive edition yeah are you looking
forward to buying that blink are you
blink oh yeah link that's the thing yeah
God yeah sure no I'm looking forward to
playing it yeah yeah I was thinking
about all these old games that are
coming at again I think about all the
old games I'd like to play which they
haven't made remix of it should be like
that game gears of war they should I
master it his 60 frames and multiplayer
that'd be awesome I wasn't thinking that
I can turn this around and turn it into
a real good segue that's why anymore is
that is not segue Brown what games would
you may remake before we talk to mike
mehar d about gears of war what will
strangle hold every stranglehold I
remember it yeah the secret the video
game sequel to hard-boiled you could
yeah that's right that's a thing the
video game sequel like entered the
matrix was the video game sequel of the
matrix I like to see you vanquish get
another credit paint that game look
beautiful anyway but yeah that frame
rate higher its throw some more effects
in their crotch slides never look better
if I could do on the table if you want
well normally get friendly show yeah
we're not gonna dad Mike my Hardy's here
hey how you doing get them pretty
sunburned [ __ ] amen brother I got a
quelle Marty you know dryers the Irish
reppin that pink lobster us I'm also
Irish Peter brand me outside though
you're playing that I mom's name is
Margo gene Lestrange oh Jesus that's the
most Irish thing about my nephew's name
is Seamus Laroy Tracy oh holy [ __ ] if I
was cosplaying as an Irish person that
that's the name I go for hey Mike
McCarty you're here to tell us about
gears of more yeah ultimate edition so
the final gears of war game by the
merriam-webster dictionary it'sit's
asked the remake of gears or one how did
you enjoy it young man I thought it was
a good remake I think it looks awesome
obviously the cuts
beans are all redone they even added a
few things you get content that was on
PC that was never on console before yeah
pretty cool cause I wasn't good enough
to make it to the console yeah we never
got it before I never played the game on
PC so it was pretty great too I mean I
know what happens but it was great to
play it you know you get it's pretty
much inserted into act 5 yeah so still
ends when you're fighting um rom on the
train wow that's a great boss life we've
all known yeah Jesus that was especially
on like insane difficult and beat all
those games on insane Wow co-op
sometimes how old you and gear whicker's
world one came out here's my one I was a
freshman in high school 15 years old no
[ __ ] so I was that was my my prime Wow
your prime now I'm waiting all downhill
from freshman year downhill now I'm just
an elderly 23 and so an office has a new
coat of paint it looks better the 60
frames a second multiplayer in all out
and mechanically does it still feel like
Gears of War one because that game came
out like it feels like an entire era of
video games has passed since gears one
came back because everyone basically
took what they did and then iterate it
on it so yeah does it still feel okay to
play yeah gears were kind of like mark
the pinnacle of third-person shooting
like cover base as far as that goes then
you know like you have so many people
that came after that but it feels it
feels better and I played 360 recently
the version yeah and especially
multiplayer having 60 frames per second
is awesome I mean just you know
swiveling to aim at someone just moving
around the camera itself doesn't really
it's not as gritty as it was and get
that you know campaign still feels the
same and it still feels great it's kind
of it's crazy that it's nine years after
and it still feels like it's one of the
better third person yeah those control
like the first game because one of the
things that I remember playing update a
bit of this in Germany was I wasn't sure
if it felt actually like the first game
was or if it if it's like gears of war 3
but it movement but in Gears of War 1
still like the same scheme but it feels
better definitely it feels closer to 2
and 3 both of which I think are better
games in the first game it also there
are subtle tweaks to the controls and
whatnot on you can't you can't do the
down crawl and multiplayer so if you get
down and multiply you guys okay in like
the later games you can kind of get
behind cover wow I didn't realize that
was added effect yeah I think it's in
two and three
be just me but yeah it's multiplayer is
still great there's not much to say
about it it's just 60 frames they edited
boxes this map it's this really small
map it's just pretty much nasha shotguns
right I'm left and right which is one
thing about this game's multiplayer that
I didn't remember it really falls back
on the shot gun fights yeah Mormons from
behind those yeah yeah and you know in
order to be good you kind of have to
master not really holding L to aim with
a shotgun or if you're going to just
really quick like quick scope almost
does thats is that still happening even
early in because one of the things about
gears and online was that the first two
weeks role was kind of a gimme it wasn't
so bad and then after like ended week to
start early three everyone was just like
doing a roll and shotgun move and
everyone was like amazing at it is it is
it difficult or is that sort of an even
playing field well there those people
that really know how to snap between
cover because the good players will they
call it bouncing I think and they'll
just pretty much use the cover mechanic
to move instead of just actually walking
or dodging yeah it so there'll be people
like sweeping between cover and then
shooting during that ok so it's crazy
and then you know you see people pulling
off like double kills doing that and I'm
not that good need to play a lot but
there are definitely top tier players
already for sure I'm not one of them but
try my best it's a tough game to review
Peter your reviews editor for video
games com and when you're tackling a
game like this like how important do you
think it is that these games are kind of
they they fit what they were before like
they're just like I guess good like we
makes of the game as we know and love or
how important is that they're like
adding new features or like catching up
with the times in terms of graphics the
great thing about reviews is that
they're subjective right so I think
that's up to their person reviewing the
game to make that call you know it's a
game like Gears of War like you know
you've said it a few times like you know
when it came out it was innovative the
things that did was we r interesting and
games have evolved a lot off of that
that base model for cover-based shooting
and and so now those things that used to
shine so bright are a little bit duller
and it's okay to cut to say that like
you know if perception changes that's
the way it should be viewed but again if
somebody really loves that stuff and
they don't really care about other games
that have come since like if it doesn't
replace their love for this one and then
that's good for them
ultimately it's important that a game
that's released and reviewed is reviewed
by the person reviewing it the way they
see it and there's there's no right
answer here I find it telling that I
guess of the sort of overall body
proposition because I'm like I'm a big
ears or fun i love all the game while
department judgment that was a bit of a
train wreck and nobody gives a [ __ ]
about Bard but like Baird but I've
already mispronounced somebody's name a
lot in a video this week I want to do it
in there to tell for I think
Kickstarter's yeah yeah exactly and the
apart like even so I'm not really that
excited about playing this like how much
do you think the fact that there they've
like done the 60 frames a second the
multiplayer and how much the fact that
they're adding all this like free stuff
like if you buy this game before
december 31st you play it before
december if you play it right so even if
you care about your boarded it so i
don't know if you could play it and not
necessarily own it yourself but if you
have you basically get the backwards
compatibility f unlocked on xbox live
whenever that stuff goes properly live
at a beta for all the games Gears of War
One the whole way through judgment and
all I want to be clear here are you
saying it unlocks the ability to play
those games are you unlock those games
you unlock those games okay yeah yeah
yeah cuz that's very different than what
you said yeah they'll be available you
only get the chance to play it yeah now
how much how important do you think that
is to the overall value proposition for
the package I think if you're a Gears
war fan this is a great way to get back
into it before coalition releases for
especially because going back to Gears
of War one one of the positive things
about the campaign that I found it was
much more intimate and personal the
characters are pretty they're kind of
static there's a few time like you know
later on you would mention earlier Dom
has to shoot his wife and yeah here's
war two and it does yeah then three
comes along and I think they made more
of an consolidated effort to actually
characterize these people instead of
making them vehicles for the action even
Anya's in it yeah honey it plays a big
part on yeah and I think that it's a
good segue for the coalition I know they
went back to it to try to figure out
what makes it gears game what can we do
well for 4 with this and I know the
gears were for one of the big things are
touting is they want to make it more
horror driven and more intimate personal
the e3 demo they showed it was kind of
really dark I mean all the gears games
are dark but it was so dark I play dark
it was the darkest demo I've ever seen
in my god down
yeah like what is going on yeah and
there's that monster chasing him on the
rooftops and I know that you know rod
fergusson was always saying that this is
like his team's training camp for years
war for our and also yeah the value of
its forty dollars just for a remaster
that alone I think is good value because
if you're a Gears fan it's worth going
back to I'm a big years fan as well but
to get two three and judgment I actually
kind of like judgment I like the arcade
that kind of twist they put on it two
and three months I think three is my
favorite Campaign wise I won't defend
myself showtimes judge me today yeah but
another the flipside of returning to a
game that's nine years old as I found I
forgot how much of the campaign revolved
around going into an area killing about
ten locusts Oh more 15 and when you hear
a gong sound you're like oh I'm gonna
move to the next area pick up a few frag
grenades pick up some ammo hopefully
find a power weapon there's a sniper
rifle which unless you're on hard corner
dawn is a satellite working yeah I can
use it here yeah a great part the
berserker is one of those few like
flashes of brilliance and I still really
enjoyed but come Act two out of five now
yeah I was just really it became a slog
later on because I was just I mean a lot
of shooters have that you know it's kill
a certain about people to get through
the you know gated by mean Jack needs
time to open the door yeah justification
there you just they introduce horde mode
like in disguise before to came out yeah
yeah exactly but there are so many times
and like I think the assumption on maybe
not the assumption but I expected it
going in to just be a better version of
the 2006 you know 360 released but there
were a few times after having played the
360 version recently about 2x to the
campaign I encountered problems in the
remaster that I didn't in the first one
oh really yeah it was a few times like
these games are better played
cooperatively like yes which I'd you
know split screen is still my favorite
way to play and you can do as well
checkers and you can do drop in drop out
whenever you want cool so like my friend
had you know dropped in he was dumb and
he was much more welcome than the AI don
because AI is still frustrating um
there's that part in act 2 where you're
avoiding the shadows and trying to shoot
propane tank yeah he's a krill away from
just shredding you and it's a cool part
if you're playing co-op it can be kind
of frustrating but it's really
frustrating when Don just keeps like
heroically running into the shadows and
then you hear the frill you hear the
krill just tear them off you see has
symbol yeah like okay I can either just
go forward kill all these guys by myself
which on hardcore is a little harder cuz
sometimes they I helps you know but I've
always played those games on hard courts
I think it's like the heroic in Halo
it's kind of a good balance between kind
of easy and like really hard yeah
challenging and a good one right it it's
like a good it's perfectly paced I think
as far as playing in that difficulty but
there are too many times we're done we
have footage I think of the Dom just
standing there in front of a turret and
and then I'd you know revive him jump
back he would stand there again it
happened four times and I was showing um
so I told someone over my desk to show
and was like is this just like me or is
this not supposed to happen no that's
kind of funny but yeah and I had a fun
time with a game I think it was a good
remaster of a game that hasn't aged as
well as I thought I would you know
they're also part times later when Dom
just wouldn't like I remember I was
standing it's in Act five and you're on
top of this essentially like a stage set
at a play and you take down this wall to
cover up where the cedar is shooting out
the unit you know the Nemesis enemies
those floating ones and Dom is supposed
to go up a turn of valve which moves you
along the catwalk yes I remember yeah
and I kept pressing lb to see where Dom
wasn't see what my objective was and it
was just Marcus saying Dom the stage
waiting Dom I I think you said it six
times because i was thinking maybe
there's an enemy that he's killing and
hasn't killed yet yeah but then i
finally found him like you know if you
hold i'll be it'll show him or anybody
he's just sitting behind cover and then
if Mark is dumb to stage and then
finally I just reload the checkpoint and
that was one of six times it happened oh
[ __ ] where they minded okay sounds like
the AI is even a little bit rougher than
it was for some right yeah where
sometimes the cutscene just wouldn't
trigger when I killed everybody you
would hear that Gong you know go to
where the cutscene is supposed to hear
because I have a pretty good memory of
the game I was like oh I'm just going
toward marks the mansion has a house
anyone getting bigger so like okay I
think maybe I did something wrong or
miss someone I'm gonna reload it see if
I just kill him faster get [ __ ] Mike f
top of me and I did it and it didn't
work and then i reloaded of like I
really i think i'm just missing somebody
and then i finally got to the point
where i walked up the same area and then
it cut to the cutscene which was a
gorgeous cutscene or just took a while
to get there Wow all right a little bit
rough around the edges as we remember it
maybe or maybe a little bit worse like
my hearty thank you so much come on tell
us all about gears of war Ultimate
Edition and what score did
you know seven seven out of ten read
that review on blanket got like in eight
a few years ago I kind of got it nice
play six I can only an eight this looks
better ah I know I just I really just
wanted to stick it to them and exactly
what you're making your own thing yeah
you guys any want to talk about we'll
talk about that later yeah I packs i'll
see you at pax you're going to pack some
point not gonna pay Medicare solid four
decks god damn five months yeah yeah son
of a [ __ ] rest of us have to wait damn
I have to weigh like a few extra days on
staying saddle just for a while Oh
Mike's got a whole day come [ __ ]
vacation poor guy in a sounders game are
you seahawks preseason no I'm just gonna
be up there for work so Seattle sander
is a fire that's a Sanders got a ship or
something oh it's they just took the
name of a body of water and edit yards
oh yeah it's called the sand Puget Sound
yes and they're gonna build a bridge
across the Puget Sound made of aircraft
carriers see that [ __ ] that's the only
thing about right that is this is
fallout that is that's some [ __ ] raid
[ __ ] that's like something hit software
would come up with yeah except they
wouldn't put water in the game because
it would have taken too many mega
textures that's the longer this week
thanks so much Peter brand for hanging
out and let us know what you think of
the show in the comment box below we'll
be back next week with more actually
wait a second we're going to be back
next week with a pre-recorded episode
because we're recording one at PAX so if
you're at Seattle and you don't even
need a pax pass actually you can just
come to this weird-ass comedy club
there's anyone not named in a comedy
club I'll take that silences know and
follow the case about Twitter can
they'll be talking about it we've got
this place rented out for the Friday
giant bomb we take it over to saturday
it's all a bunch of cool stuff going on
when hub the lobby record it there and
then we're going to broadcast it next
week as well so that'll be a
pre-recorded show so sorry the news is a
little bit late but yeah tune in then
and thanks everyone production stuff in
the back Mary Kish josho air it a dime
ahora que anyone else not really see you
next week fine
you
you
you
you